un carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
bienvenidos a este nuevo número de
carrusel de las artes
hoy los invitamos a descubrir con
nosotros uno de los lugares más
pintorescos y emblemáticos de la capital
francesa con más que un barrio que ha
sido fuente de inspiración para artistas
e intelectuales
[Música]
deambular hemos por las típicas calles
de piedra de mónaco para ver la basílica
el mirador sobre parís y la conocida
plaza de texto o plaza de los pintores
visitaremos el museo de mónaco y sus
jardines o no hay testigos de la
efervescencia artística de la belle
époque la vida nocturna es intensa en lo
mágico donde se perpetúa la tradición de
los cabarets músicos y café concert en
nuestra crónica musicales hablaremos de
algunos cantantes ilustres que
escribieron la historia de mi marca
[Música]
sin duda uno de los barrios más
genuinamente parisinos un lugar que
conserva el encanto de antaño ubicado en
la colina más alta de parís a 130 metros
de altura
para llegar a la cima se puede tomar el
funicular o subir a pie las 222
escaleras rodeadas de jardines
y aquí en lo más alto de la colina de
mónaco se encuentra la basílica del
sagrado corazón donde nos espera nuestra
guía en este paseo vamos a verlo
[Música]
y vamos a darle la bienvenida en
carrusel de las artes a viviana rubio
bibiana muchísimas gracias por
recibirnos en este tu barrio tu vives
aquí en mi marca eres artista
audiovisual y guía turístico sin manera
carolina efectivamente estamos en uno de
los sitios más visitados de parís es una
de las vistas más lindas que tenemos
aquí algo que salta a la vista cuando
uno viene a algo más es esta basílica
del sagrado corazón que es blanca y que
es imponente como tú le dices es blanca
imponente porque imagínate que a pesar
de que fue hecha hace no mucho tiempo la
empezaron a hacer en 1835 esta iglesia
tiene el aire de ser una iglesia muy
antigua fue hecha por arquitecto abadía
y él se inspiró en el arte bizantino y
en el arte románico cuando él decidió
hacer esta catedral escoge una piedra
diferente a las que usan en todas las
construcciones de parís que es blanca
pero además se limpia sola con el agua y
además algo que no hemos dicho es que
justamente lo que da el nombre a esta
basílica es
mosaico que hay en el interior que es el
sagrado corazón efectivamente este
mosaico es uno de los mosaicos más
grandes hechos en el siglo 20
este jesucristo resucitado tienen los
brazos abiertos con el sagrado corazón
muy importante esta iglesia es el
símbolo de la expiación de los pecados
porque francia después de la revolución
francesa había sufrido bastante luego
tuvimos de la comuna de parís luego en
este momento también vivimos en la
pérdida de la guerra de la prusia
francia estaba destruida no
necesitábamos hacer algo que nos una a
todos que una toda francia pues bueno
hicimos una iglesia del sagrado corazón
[Música]
y este barrio de marco también es
conocido porque aquí vivieron muchos
artistas sí imagínate que aquí vivieron
artistas como bangkok
modigliani renoir picasso georges break
juan gris volvieron muchísimos artistas
toulouse lautrec este barrio antes no
era un barrio antes era un pueblo aparte
de parís una situación bastante bucólica
porque imagínate que eso está llenos de
campo habían muchos bares y había
realmente un ambiente bastante festivo
web y bohemio entonces toda esta gente
que venía aquí y creaban un sitio muy
importante que aquí emblemático en
montmartre se llama levantó el agua y
entonces resulta que los artistas en
estos artistas varios artistas no eran
jóvenes picasso tenía 19 años cuando
vino acá alquilaron esta casa en una
casa grande y todos viven ahí creaban
juntos en este sitio elevado al agua se
creó el cubismo y justamente bibiana
aquí en mónaco hay una institución que
retrasa esa historia el vínculo entre
los artistas como marc es el museo de
mou más para que fuimos a ver
[Música]
un capítulo fundamental del arte moderno
se escribió en omaha es lo que muestra
el museo de mónaco 60 años de
efervescencia creativa de 1870 a 1930 de
la mano de jóvenes llamados picasso
howard bach o modigliani quienes soñaban
con crear lenguajes nuevos
[Música]
y contamos la transformación de mónaco
de pueblecito a centro artístico la vida
bohemia de los cabarets y la fundación
del sándwich y su teatro de sombras uno
de los primeros pintores fue cristiano a
quien se instaló en mónaco para pintar
el molino de la galette el trigo famoso
susana baladón moje su trillo y andrew
del trabajo aquí 14 años hemos
reconstruido el taller de trabajo de
suzanne valadon que puede visitarse en
el museo
tributo a la colección el museo pone de
relieve la historia del bateau lavoir
una de las residencias de artistas más
famosas del país y de la historia el
óleo pero las farc se tasan portón por
no el bateau-lavoir es un lugar mítico
para el arte fue allí donde picasso
pintó en 1907 las señoritas de avignon
el cuadro que dio origen al cubismo ese
lugar es todavía hoy un taller de
artistas que marcó para siempre la
historia de la toma
[Música]
en los jardines de este lugar
impresionaron mucho al guaje quien pintó
varios cuadros aquí como el columpio o
el torso de anna estos jardines que
ahora se llaman los jardines con hojas
son una de las atracciones del museo es
muy fácil entender por qué los artistas
a sucumbieron al encanto de este lugar
y viene ahora nos encontramos en otro
punto neurálgico de mou macro que es
esta plaza de texto
imagínate que esta plaza de tráfico
quiere decir montículo y tenemos esta
plaza llena de terrazas y artistas que
antes venían espontáneamente hoy en día
tenemos muchos artistas tenemos
retratistas tenemos paisajistas que han
sido elegidos por la alcaldía local para
estar aquí y justamente a propósito de
estos artistas fuimos al encuentro de
una de ellas que trabaja aquí todos los
días en la plaza de teatro vamos a
conocerla
mi nombre es natacha carrillo yo soy
retratista en esta plaza hace 30 años de
trabajo aquí nosotros somos artistas
profesionales o sea que pagamos por
nuestro lugar y compartimos un metro
cuadrado con otro artista porque somos
muchos en esta plaza 250 artistas mi
trabajo es algo que es una pasión para
mí bueno normalmente como yo tengo un
carácter latinoamericano que soy muy
abierta hablo mucho con la gente les
explico el tiempo que dura un retrato si
es en blanco y negro si es en color que
esto es un recuerdo para toda la vida es
lo que más les gusta a la gente porque
la placita de esta conocida en el mundo
entero el barrio de montmartre así que
mucha gente lo hacen por eso porque es
una tradición hacerse un retrato aquí
la historia de mamá está ligada a la
vida nocturna y a los cabarets que
florecieron durante la belle époque y
que popularizaron el french cancan el
molino rojo por ejemplo es una de las
salas de espectáculos más conocidas en
el mundo pero en marcos surgieron
diferentes tipos de espectáculo es lo
que nos explicó el especialista en la
materia david a quien yo amo el cabaré
es un número mítico hoy en día se usa la
palabra cabaret para designar diferentes
tipos de espectáculos pero en realidad
el cabaret en el siglo 19 era
simplemente un lugar donde se podía
beber en 1881 un hombre llamado rodolfo
solís inventó algo nuevo lugar para
beber con un piano y donde el público
podía escuchar canciones poemas y textos
literarios lo llamaron el show y por ahí
pasaron escritores como verle él o los
pianistas eric sentí división
rodolf salís creo así un nuevo modelo de
espectáculo en esa época había muchos
café consejos pero eran lugares para
comer
ruidosos con una escena donde los
cantantes tienen que gritar para hacerse
escuchar además como estaban sometidos a
las insulto en el cabaret en cambio los
artistas estaban al mismo nivel que el
público y robots salir se preocupó
porque la canción fuera algo
verdaderamente artístico
[Música]
hoy en día la sala más conocida es el
mulá bus que se presenta como el cabaret
más antiguo de parís
es verdad que hay mesas se escuchan
canciones pero yo diría que corresponde
más al modelo de music-hall es un
espectáculo llamado revista con una
temática y varios números como en el
circo y las bailarinas por supuesto
atletas
es también el lugar donde nacieron
numerosas leyendas de la canción
francesa y es lo que vamos a ver ya
mismo en nuestra crónica musical con
natalia olivares hola natalia hola maria
carolina natal y nos diste hoy cita aquí
para hablar de un lugar emblemático en
la historia de la canción francesa
exactamente estamos en el que apague
lola para ayer y por aquí pasaron y
desde 1914 todos los grandes artistas
como charles aznavour rafael y edit
[Música]
como se la llamaba cantaba efectivamente
acá en sus momentos más pobres vivió en
las calles y en su momento de gloria
vivió en departamentos muy lujosos y hay
canciones por ejemplo como la de ojos
azules y el de padín y los que recuerdan
mucho esta vida con altos y bajos pero
pero hay una canción que representa
mucho más el abismo más que es la del
charlas de voz salas lago maría carolina
exactamente
[Música]
brito
natalie no podemos hablar de monarcas
sin mencionar a la diva venida del
extranjero dálida una cantante muy
conocida en los años 70 y 80 cálida es
un artista ítalo egipcia que vino aquí
hasta este barrio como migrante a
francia para probar suerte y con su
acento muy particular conquistó las
salas más míticas de la escena y de la
canción francesa el público de todos los
cabaret e incluso y más adelante se
convirtió en un icono de la escena drag
queen aquí
obviamente
[Música]
por menor
gracias natalia y qué te parece si
terminamos este programa especial aquí
en mónaco con un artista de la nueva
canción francesa se llama petit prince y
justamente tiene un tema de visión lo q
filmado aquí en mónaco muchísimas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
cuídense mucho y hasta la próxima
[Música]